hello and welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for the just remember the
surge commercials yeah I do I'm old this
is the show where we talk about the
honest trail that you hopefully just
watched and if you stick around to the
end there's some deleted scenes in this
one I think some cut jokes
that's Joestar there's no Canadian purge
is there I saw your your driveways
little icy over there so I fixed it up
for you I thought you always add me on
purge night but no I'm sorry these were
a series of movies that are I was
surprised at how much I didn't mind them
yeah they're it's a cool premise that I
think we say they never fully deliver on
mm-hmm but I was engaged throughout most
of them I thought that it was an
interesting mix of action in horror that
leaned too heavy in the action direction
I think this is such a good horror setup
and the first movie was the only one
that really even stayed in that lane
yeah the third one feels like white
house down yes yeah but with masks yeah
so yeah well they're totally like
wavering around where I think the bull's
eye should be that's just one man's
opinion wouldn't you think Dan yeah you
know it's it's it's an interesting
concept
they're very political mmm which I was
surprised by there's a cut joke about
how why doesn't talk about the pub these
politics because they're very much more
overt than some of the other politics
that people seem to find and and other
franchises yeah it's all right
I don't mind any of them yeah I didn't
find that I finished any of them I was
just like that was time wasted yeah yeah
I'm not like pumped about the new one
but if I have to watch it then I'll be
like alright let's see where this goes
yeah do we just not have much to say
about the purse I don't think we did
weirdly no all right no you you taught
us a comment slower is our purge let's
just watch then in a world full of
senseless violence political strife and
corporate greed three movies about those
things also exist on a parallel so the
purge energy more than maybe they forget
live never purge night a new American
holiday where all crimes are legal but
everyone goes straight for murderer
yeah so well I'll just open it up to the
floor what would you guys do on purge
night I would like steel I would order a
lot of food and not pay for it
definitely do that don't pay for food I
don't think they deliver on purge night
I want that perceive the pizza delivery
guy and prayer it's like 30 to 30
minutes on purge night or the manager
kills you yeah cuz people gotta eat yeah
that's your keeps it doesn't get there
in 30 minutes you kill the driver yeah
yeah that's that's motivation is what
that is purge pizza
please make purge pizza we did done the
reason I avoided these movies for so
long was because of them the murder
thing not because I'm like squeamish but
because every preview starts with the
the purge PSA voiceover that's like
every crime including murder which is so
well it's stupid it's smart at the same
time or whatever it's stupid because
that's no one would ever go for that and
who in their right mind would like who's
dumb enough to be like I'm gonna do the
murdering and not be murdered
exactly yeah it's like everyone's so
confident that they are going to be the
murderers I wish I have the confidence
of a murderer everyone's a shooting like
you ever play paintball but like there's
no teams
all going home with welts yeah
everyone's gonna stay inside and they're
gonna do things that are in direct
violation of like community policies on
reddit yeah oh it would be so much
piracy happening of the night of the
purge yeah and I think as you were
saying was a the purge falls like a
month before tax day yeah everyone
dresses
everyone cheat on your taxes like
everybody is you know obviously you
don't get retro actively charged for
crimes that you commit so yeah report
that non income or under report that
income file your taxes by 7:00 a.m. on
March the 22nd you're home free well
white-collar criminals don't get
punished anyways the smart dumb thing
was like murder is the is what everyone
goes to on the purge but the what's
smart about is that like even the
government in world knows that that's
not really the reason the reason is to
like get rid of the poor oh yeah yeah
they say it's to release all your urges
and I'm like that doesn't work
psychology says if you get angry you
just get more angry the rest of the year
but but also if the government just says
something to you enough a lot of people
be like okay I gotta go stop somebody
it's very much kind of a Hot Fuzz
mentality it's like the greater good for
the greater good the greater like what's
you know yes it's terrible that it's
murder but it keeps crime low and our
influence our economy right guys yeah
the day after the purge I want to see
that movie that's just the cleanup and
the day after is that the agents of
shield show for the purge yes yes
sweeping up arms let's keep in an annual
free-for-all that you either treat like
Halloween for Psychopaths or excuse to
throw a really boring dinner party as a
ferreting party
Betty eat drink go back to that shot of
steamed vegetables vegetables in the pan
that were like completely uncooked it's
definitely a PA just got various
vegetables they're not even cooked I
wanna bet those by the fake eggs and
Zetas steel is that like an entire head
of bok choy just dumped in there well we
didn't say it was a good dinner just
boring yeah
prepare for three zombie movies if the
zombies were just regular folks who need
therapy in three parts where the people
don't take the purge seriously enough no
don't don't say that okay fine pause you
can spring that on someone but you can't
spring that on them like a day or two
before this right you prepare for that
all year it's like you know frank grillo
the purges in three months if you can't
stay at home they'll do what you got to
do don't hire shady people that you
don't know yeah let's vet triple
background usually infiltrated July 4th
is this week and my local grocery store
closes at 4 o'clock okay there's no way
that someone's gonna be like at at
Kroger buying chips 20 minutes before
the purge is purge anarchy with Matt
Saracen and and what's-her-face
yeah where they decide to go grocery
shopping had to get some plantain chips
so far away from their house so far yeah
and then break down on the 6th Street
bridge the only location in Los Angeles
yes and get trapped it's just like no
you should if let's say you shop on the
day of the purge go in that morning yeah
or if there's like 18,000 rouses in Los
Angeles
I assure you there's one near there you
know what you probably have that old
frozen dinner that you save for just an
occasion like this yeah like weird beans
in your pantry
why do I have a pack of currants grunts
all right well [ __ ] it's better you
don't have to purge thing yeah my like
my growing up my mother would have
willfully purged and to avoid going to
the grocery store like on Thanksgiving
and like why would you beat the purge
crowds that's what I'm saying
beat the PERT come on rich crowds yeah
let's keep going come on hard store bus
then get kidnapped by an old white
murderer called and are rescued by a POC
X monkey da whole movie is like one big
glad I called that canvas actors but
infinitely less subtlety right out the
first horror movie with Cersei Lannister
in a low-budget home invasion movie
let's have shots of dimly lit hallways
and have shots of people doing PvP
emotes at security cameras tea bagging
in election year cracking the tension of
the first went down in two generic gun
driven action movies with just no
flashes of perjury to make you say I
hope they really embrace the concept in
the next one do you like it a social
commentary failed and metaphor too bad
because these movies have a message as
subtle as the giant blood letters on the
Lincoln Memorial that aren't afraid to
deal with class who dies tonight
immigrants joking me on job seven years
ago when I first came in from Mexico
insurance companies they just raised a
premium on my purge covers by thousands
capitalism guns we worship at the altar
of Smith & Wesson insurance companies
capitalism and gun governmental ID white
supremacists Russians pretending to be
Americans we love you
a shuttle Paul Ryan with a spaceport
alright leader named Donald T it's way
too on-the-nose 2014-2015 yeah yeah
there was no like election year came out
way before the election came out in
summer of 2016
yeah but that's the thing I don't
understand is like those are like some
of the crunchiest granola issues and yet
I've never heard any anyone raging about
politics and the purge movies as I've
heard them talk about politics and well
I think worse other films yeah I guess
it's different if you just say what you
believe rather than implying you believe
in equality by by casting girls like
that's that's a gracious that gets a
tirade but actually saying people
deserve equal I mean I'm a liberal guy
and I was much in purged election year
and I was like for sure the Bill Maher
of like I agree the rec line about
insurance companies and stuff but Laura
Dern had purple hair and hold up man
what heard oh boy branch the purge purge
purge the word so settle in for a
franchise with amazing potential that
could be a little more creative in its
execution instead of just creative in
its executions in films that make you
reconsider the value of unleashing your
violent impulses killing doesn't help
anything by showing the scene after
scene of awesome stylized violence
that's a good guy you can't have sliced
ice
Zack Snyder watchman he did this before
we could even show him any clothes so I
just told him that just say like
positive things about we oh there was
sharp-eyed notice you know there might
be a certain special someone in that
guillotine we've been leaning on a lot
this is our editors but we certainly
didn't say no to it it effectively
expressly said yes in fact we said great
idea do it go to our that was our last
job before sunrise Rushmore Jose cancer
see the punisher thing that surgeon
can't get to break president I said
Bernie would have Spring Breakers I want
to purge Wall Street with machetes and
jump scares I don't meet the Foley
jump-scare guys I think it just slams a
door over
that's a game kids play yeah I didn't
get that one either vertical video in
the White House
this truly is that it's our future
they're us all televisions vertical
video yes or watch an Instagram TV right
there in the White House but this
election year takes place and I maintain
this and we'll look it up and I think
I'm backed up by our new friends and
family at fandom on the purge wiki that
I used famous is that election here
takes place in like 20 40 or some I've
seen conflicting information some say it
takes place 18 years after the purge
Anarchy which means Frank grows 8 8
Petrino she groped the the events the
pre-credit events take place no I
two years after anarchy and then it
flashes forward eighteen years
I think I saw two things one of them
said it said set three years after the
purge a nickname like that makes sense
and then I saw another synopsis that
said set 18 years after the purge
anarchy no it set three because then
also the the bloody stranger has taken
over for Omar yeah Michael again yeah
very well yeah but they have an age
though like is the thing like so it's
all I'm gonna do our purge math for us
this is all this does is draw attention
to why you need a consistent resource
like our friends our new friends yeah
that's right that's where I drew from
but but again there's other info out
there and look yeah I just couldn't find
where in the movie it gave a specific
date for myself to count from very
different so the internet difficulty you
know it was fine until they said
spider-man homecoming was set three
years after oh my god some text some
title card editor dictated this entire
world would see you timeline see they'll
release three movies addressing it don't
worry guys climb it up I mean your
Netflix password or rip the tag off a
mattress or something story it's that
training dad Max Fisher American Psycho
junior Rory Gilmore slay Queen slay
Prince upper jaw crossbow and president
nice lady the United States pretty soon
probably
we didn't want to get to over you know
for all the hoops people jump through to
find politics and Star Wars shouldn't
these movies be the ones people yell
about Florida is the key you have to get
the others if trying to win Florida is a
smart idea for you you might be too dumb
to be President
yes yeah I did spend the prevailing
wisdom for ever ever yeah try to win
Florida okay in a presidential election
oh wow what a novel concept I do want to
see the Florida elder purge in the in
the Gulf comedian
yeah just like a slow-motion golf club
beatdowns yeah or just in a retirement
home
I mean or just like yet the longest
balls are dipping into someone's soup
[Laughter]
it's pretty sad that even in the
dystopian future of the purge the United
States is still using the electoral
college well here's my big problem with
the purge and look things happen in the
electoral college is amiss but like they
voted for a purge government for at
least four presidential cycles again
with my dates but I did I imagine
there's like at least fifteen purges by
now many herds they kept voting them
back in on a Pro purge platform yeah and
clearly there are still free and fair
elections because the whole plot of
election years like we got to stop her
cuz she's gonna win they're not gonna
like rigged the election they're just
gonna try to kill her so they still have
elections and people got out to the
polls and for like yeah let's keep it up
isn't that what you would do if you were
the government is move the election to
purge night and then then it's legal to
rig an election so so many questions
this is why I would not be on the
streets on the purge like pages there's
a lot of corruption so that like the
opposition parties they would just be
sort of patsies that are like I'm also
for the purge vote for me I'm Jamie and
like this lady was like the first real
threat ya know yeah it all I know is it
did take 20 years for people to finally
start getting a little frustrated about
the purge yeah much like The Hunger
Games much like people gotten like maybe
the Quarter Quell comes around and
you're like flower really doing the
greatest hits of our murder competition
it also doesn't look back it also
doesn't work because the whole point was
to get rid of like poor people and mom
and pops and so that they can just move
a bunch of like American girls into
those areas undesirables in general yeah
but they're everywhere all every
everyone who would the purge movies
would consider an undesirable still
there as an election year right with
with their crappy shops on valuable real
estate it's not working yeah we still in
business yeah he's still doing great and
it was only only an election year when
they realized they could use it to get
rid of like political undesirables yeah
it's just the lack of imagination in the
purge franchise is what's killing me but
it's such a fertile ground for
imagination so I'll keep watching them
yeah and we'll keep asking dumb
questions yeah yeah yeah and maybe
you'll keep watching this show we'll
find out next week when you come back
for another episode mars trailer
commentaries I'm Ron Burgundy
[Music]
you